okay everybody Donald Glover's animated
Deadpool series on TV that he created
for FX was cancelled by the network with
sources citing creative differences
saying Glover was parting ways with FX
and Marvel television and FX making a
comment about Glover not being able to
do it because we had a packed schedule
now Glover responded in the coolest way
possible he tweeted that he wasn't too
busy to work on Deadpool and he tweeted
a parody finale script of the animated
series it mocks the whole situation a
ton of other stuff in classic Deadpool
fashion now this was an actual script
for the show we don't think it might
have lifted some jokes or some platinum
it's really this was a mock script this
was like a sample of like hey just to
show you that I did have time to work on
it
here is a 14 page script with the kind
of tone and humor that you would have
seen had this show not been cancelled
well I thought we'd do something fun
here guys
do something a little bit different I
think we would actually read the script
with all of you as a staged reading with
the four of us to play all the parts
it's only 14 pages we have we have the
scripts printed out here there's only
four characters and it's hilarious it's
really great now again this is not our
work the the script was written by
Donald Glover and his brother who Co
collaborates with but Glover did tweet
it out there for the world to see so
hopefully he won't mind
so just to do some casting here Phillip
will be reading our exposition in action
for the script I will read for Deadpool
mod will read for the roles of Ozzy and
Keith and blind Al and Sam will read for
the character of Zachary little pivotal
role and just put that on there pivotal
Zechariah is the name though not pivotal
okay take away Phillip all right it
didn't solemn silent okay Deadpool the
animated series finale written by Donald
Glover exterior Kenyon Savannah Day
Deadpool is asleep in a Jeep that's
driving down a dirt road he's sitting
next to an African woman who looks in
her late 30s as young Kiki
Deadpool suddenly wakes up screaming
don't let Ben Carson ours operate on me
where the hell am I you're in Kenya I
picked you up from the airport you were
very drunk when I arrived security
helped me carry you to the car doesn't
sound like me and it takes a lot to get
me drunk you were passed out in an empty
duty-free oh yeah you guys are the ones
with the Rhino yes
I'm Sen Kiki J Kazuki SZ and Kiki you
know what I'm just gonna call you the
Greek freak and John Kiki frowns doesn't
seem cool Deadpool ignores it yeah so
y'all paid me in Bitcoin
I'm surprised so you were the first to
agree to that whatever it takes what
surprised you took the job actually you
don't seem like the animal lover type oh
don't get me wrong I'd rip that horn off
myself if a poacher paid me enough I'm
Jeremy Meeks when it comes to that bag
oh but I also love everything right now
you know I used to wear a ton of echo
back in the day I was a huge g-unit fan
had the whole fit still got some shirts
you want some echo shirts no yeah me
neither so where's this big grey nutsack
skin covered unicorn we're hiding in
Sudan right now he's very weak we've
been doing all we can but if he stays in
captivity he will die the problem is the
poachers they're everywhere and they've
been waiting for oh my god you see what
sana Lathan bit Beyonce's face wait oh
thank god it was Jennifer Lawrence I
already hate her it's fine
he continues to scroll and stare at his
phone as um Kiki keeps driving awkwardly
he looks for a moment then goes back to
scrolling it's an addiction so if it
seems like I'm not paying attention to
you it's because I agree the what you
say exterior mountainside day the Jeep
pulls through brush and into a clearing
there are 20 armed guards in uniform
blocking a tunnel opening they let the
Jeep pass through and they park in the
tunnel the Jeep is blasting rubbing off
the paint by ybn Namir as they pull in
that song was interesting yeah that's
nice really him and rich the kid is all
I really listened to lately rich the kid
not as much so he be cloud chasing wow
this is cool well not actually cool but
like Vegas cool chainsmokers cool
who are you talking to the people
watching the people reading this you
made it
Zechariah mu Phi walks over hello I'm
Zechariah Sudan's keeper we really
appreciate you doing this
don't thank me thank the 700 bitcoins
you're paying me oh my god it dropped
that much
I went from Johnny Depp in Pirates of
the Caribbean to Johnny Depp in Pirates
of the Caribbean the ride
Deadpool pinches the bridge of his nose
and push a frustration where's this
interior mountain tunnel day a large
Rhino stands eating by a rock wall
Deadpool as young Kiki and Zechariah
walk up to him
this is Sudan the last male northern
white rhino on the earth hi when he dies
a piece of us dies as well pieces of me
die all the time it's fine also can't
you guys just grab some rhino semen to
make more rhinos we prefer to do it
naturally but in case something does
happen to him in the wild we did have
semen samples taken so this isn't even
really the last male rhino
y'all can Jurassic Park this whenever
you want this feels like a waste of my
time I assure you it isn't
whatever whatever you'd be doing instead
wouldn't be as significant a be jaqen
llamas from eleven-year-olds Zecharia
energy and kiki stare what fortnight
hello Oh Jack and llamas from where the
new your old sounds awful that's not
what I'm saying I'm not - cashy 69 I'm
an amazing rapper Zechariah and Ezra and
Kiki are still confused Wow
nothing's landing our cultures are very
different we have so much to teach each
other exterior African savannah day a
large flatbed released his Sudan out
into the open the armed guards rally
around and make sure he's safe as Jen
kiki and Zechariah away from the chief
be careful we only need you to follow
him until he mates then you can collect
your price I gotta follow him until he
mates man this job this ain't worth it
bitcoin status alert holy Jeff Bezos I
will protect him with my life
cut to exterior African savannah later
Zechariah as gen Kiki and the armed
guards drive away so I guess it's just
you and me
should be a fun script Sudan just stands
there chewing oh I see
this is gonna be a castaway Wilson
relationship where I just
I just talked to myself through you the
whole time cuz to be honest it was
feeling like an Ace Ventura when nature
calls ripoff which was really excited
about Sudan choose he does come out of a
rhinos ass in that mmm castaway it is
Sudan choose what's the Wi-Fi exterior
African savannah later Deadpool in Sudan
are walking through the brush it is very
hot but damn Sudan keeps walking you're
gonna love me by the way I'm an amusing
and charismatic wingman if I'm telling
the truth
Sudan says nothing obviously I don't
know why I'm here either I think the
writers just mad or bored we'll find out
together I guess together stirred and
stops and defecates good call
Deadpool stands still for exactly 6
seconds most people don't think I wear a
diaper under here probably cuz I don't
listen can you find a female in like the
next 15 minutes I got Kings tickets
Sudan just stares off
Deadpool's Bitcoin alert goes off he
checks Jesus this isn't worth my time
again did he
Jesus I'm gonna need that horn bruh
Deadpool pulls out his sword alert goes
off again PD oh wow you want to go to a
Kings game with me co2 interior African
savannah de Sudan is chewing on grass
Deadpool is sitting against the tree you
know I'm not mad about this whole
cancelled thing I actually think it's a
good thing I mean it's not even a good
time to have violent gun-loving white
man raining on TV
other than president sudan keeps chewing
you know if this was last week tonight
people to laughed mmm would have clapped
sudan turns and scratches a tree with
his horn I mean I get it maybe they just
want to sell toys and this style of
comedy isn't it it's more haha but I'm
mad I get that
Sudan shakes then continues eating grass
do you think they cancel the show cuz of
racism Sudan continues eating grass yeah
but all the writers were black and the
references were pretty black - I heard
they went over the lunch budget ordering
Jamaican food at least once a week Sudan
eats you're right black panther maybe we
were alienating our white audience no we
did a whole goat yoga episode
damn was that it more eating no the
Taylor Swift episode yeah no they had to
have loved that script Sudan walks away
you kidding me
Deadpool gets up in chases him that
episodes hilarious Sudan does not look
he just keeps walking what the Marvel
stuff I said in it all I said was Marvel
was trying to sell toys to
seven-year-old boys and 50 rolled
pedophiles that's just funny
they're cool they get it sedan keeps
walking oh now I'm the [ __ ]
that's fine Sudan Sudan stops bites a
bush of colorful flowers what do you
what do I want I want to know why I want
the real story if you have enough data
you can predict the future it's all
that's left Google Amazon Facebook sedan
grunts yeah Facebook kick them all
they're down it just feels like everyone
wants something different but no one
wants to do anything different to get it
doesn't Marvel have enough feel-good
minority shows everyone supports but
doesn't watch I mean I think our show
would have been funny I just wanted a
place to be honest I guess that place is
freeform sooo damn stairs stairs that in
for a moment then walks off dead ball
follows exterior African savannah later
they come to a clearing the Sun is
setting in front of them it's very
beautiful the orange and browns blend
together this should be drawn like super
well it's a really beautiful place and
it gives a sense of solace we're all
kind of looking for wow this is really
beautiful I really needed a quiet moment
they said silent for a moment it's a
moment of true peace you know what
you're all right for a virgin did he hmm
Deadpool pulls out his phone suddenly
Deadpool is splattered with bullets
about twenty gunshots go off from an
automatic Deadpool turns around and
armed guards come from the brush y'all
Sacramento police deform guards look at
each other
Deadpool pulls out his own guns ha just
kidding I've actually I've actually got
guns you should have killed me when he
had the chance like the NYPD he flips
into the air and sprays back to the
guards they're both shot multiple times
but one stumbles over to Sudan and pulls
the pin from a grenade that strapped to
his vest and he collapses my bitcoins
Deadpool runs over and collapses on the
guard slash grenade it
loads Deadpool's entire abdomen bursts
out of his back black bile sprays
everywhere is that blood or did I eat
beets
clapping comes from the broad a brush
zechariah walks out with more armed
guards it was me the whole time what
what are you talking about
I'm the one selling the Rhino hi every
Deadpool's confused and still bleeding
you can see his intestines are literally
falling out of him as he gets up and
walks over to zechariah what the hell
are you talking about didn't you see all
the clues I left I'm the villain
Deadpool stairs I own the last two
female rhinos I'm using the sperm
impregnating and making more rhinos to
sell the ivory at a price i dictate dude
I'm sorry I've been on my own journey I
didn't see any clues I left them
everywhere yeah I'm sorry I shouldn't
have I shouldn't clear I just assumed
you were looking for stealing them
I didn't plan this was a classic when
nature calls it's my bad my apologies
they stay in for a moment
suddenly they both begin shooting each
other Deadpool flips over Zechariah and
shoots four armed guards
Deadpool rushes another guard and slices
him in half with his katana swords sorry
you had to split two more guards shoot
at Deadpool he hops towards them while
dodging bullets he cuts the guards up
with his swords again I see you're
dancing but can I cut in a guard runs a
Deadpool screaming with a hunting knife
in his hand Deadpool takes a stab at the
chest but counters with the jumping
swipe that cuts the guard from growing
to head save me a slice
one last guard appears with a rocket
launcher before he can get his shot off
Deadpool throws his sword and
decapitates the guard the rocket flies
vertically into the sky white guys give
the best head no please no more
Deadpool turns to find zechariah
standing near sedan no more one-liners
they're awful why'd you even hire me for
this if you were the bad guy
why pay me to protect this dinosaur I
needed a fall guy a patsy plus when I
hired you Bitcoin was trading for 2
cents a coin yet
crazy summer listen I'll pay you a
hundred thousand cash right now just
leave me with the Beast and it's yours
no way I've come to love the little guy
because in a way he reminds me of me
ugly and something people only cared
about after like a million years
Deadpool's Bitcoin alert goes off deity
he looked at his phone and then his jaw
drops really I should went litecoin like
that reddit nerd told me
Ranas all yours pal Deadpool begins to
walk away as Sudan groans in the
background the creature actually seems
sad
dead pulls Bitcoin I learned alert goes
off again TD yes I knew it be rich
bitcoin is the future that pull turns of
Zechariah
sorry but I'll need your money and Sudan
is my friend Zakaria furrows his brow
and anger he quickly dropped his gun but
Deadpool draws faster he fires one shot
hit Zakaria right between the eyes
killing him pretty much instantly take
notes teachers of America someday you'll
have to make a high-pressure shot like
that let's go home Sudan the to walk off
into the sunset it's beautiful and
everything feels right in the distance
we hear Deadpool's bitcoin let go off
did he it was Santa Lathan cut to
interior Deadpool's house de Deadpool's
on his couch drinking a cup of tea he's
wearing a rhino skin coat with the head
as a hood there was a dog on a leash by
him two movers are bringing in a piano
yeah move it there right there it's fine
the movers placed a piano and leave
blind owl walks in wow you really are a
cold son of a [ __ ] huh no I made the
best parts of Sudan just something I'll
keep forever
Deadpool pulls out two ivory-handled
pistols see the dog barks at al boom was
a dog for oh it's a seeing-eye dog I'm
drinking this rhino horn powder tea and
I should have a pretty intense erection
for six hours I figured I should be
prepared for the worst yeah I see what
about me Oh
I saved you some of the pot calm down
blind a whole excited Li runs to the
kitchen to get her TV Deadpool sits
alone and toasts his tea cup in the air
this is for you Sudan may your clone
live on forever the end on screen and
loving memory of suit
and the last male white rhino beer yeah
good job don't cook this is soot yeah
and I'm sorry if you know my acting
didn't do you're awesome delivery
justice because you would have crushed
this well comment down below to let us
know what you thought about this the
script and enbe channel on her at least
my acting all these great jokes but and
what part of Donnell Glover's take on
Deadpool that you're most bummed about
missing out on and as reminders
subscribe to new rock stars for news and
insight into all the stuff that you love
Deadpool general Marvel news everything
thanks everybody